This video is made possible by brilliant.
You're going to learn more about
brilliant later in today's video,
but if you'd like to learn
more about the right now,
you can got a brilliant at
all forward slash biographics.
You'll also find a link
in the description below.
He was the most influential
thinker in world history,
a man whose ideas permeated
every sector of society.
He is the father of modern logic,
the inventor of the sons of biology,
and the founder of ethical reasoning.
This body Tonia,
small fragments of his writing,
surviving to our times.
His influence on both the western and
the Islamic world has been profound in
this week's by graphics.
We discover the brilliance of Aristotle,
the details of Aristotle's life,
a sketchy.
We know that he was born in 384 BC in the
Greek Macedonian town of stuck area on
the north coast of the GMC.
His father,
Nica Marcus was the quarter
physician to the Macedonian King.
I'm an interest the seconds it is believed
that Aristotle's mother faced us was
descended from Greek aristocracy,
the couple and three children
with aristotle being the youngest.
He had assistant named Aaron Nestor and
a brother named Ron Ness stores and they
come back has died when
aristotle was only 13.
His mother died soon after and he was
raised through his teenage years by his
older sister's husband,
proximus by the age of 17 aristotle.
He was sent to Athens to
pursue higher education.
They are enrolled at Plato's academy.
Plato was the most renowned thinker of
the time who himself had been taught by
the great socrates.
The academy had been found 20 years
earlier and was situated beside an olive
grove outside of the city walls
rather than a formal school with a set
curriculum and to clear delineation
between teacher and students.
The academy provided an informal setting
whether master plato was pose problems
to be pondered by his students.
Instead of listening to lectures,
the students were encouraged to engage
in dialectic discussion in order to
establish a truth by means
of reasoned argument.
The main subjects under discussion,
well philosophy,
mathematics and destroy enemy.
Aristotle studied at the
Academy for 20 years,
advancing from students to
teach teacher during this time.
He developed a great respect and
a close friendship with Plato,
the two men,
however,
they did have some fundamental
philosophical differences.
As a result,
when Plato died in 347 bce,
aristotle,
his most brilliant students was not
offered the directorship of the academy.
That privilege instead went to
Plato's nephews abusive post.
Shortly thereafter,
Aristotle left the academy apparently
unhappy with the direction that it was
taking.
It is also possible that he was keen
to get out of Athens as a result of the
tide of anti Macedonian
send them and in the city,
Iris does a little hand by this time,
developed some important friendships
which would pave the way forward for him.
One of them was hmi as king of the
Greek city of tenures in Asia Minor.
How many us was a former
students at Plato's academy.
Upon hearing of the master's death,
he invited aristotle to
come to our tennis irs,
sessionals and assets.
The city which faced the island of lesbos
that he became the head of a group of
philosophers establishing
a brand new academy.
His focus there was only the
observation of the natural world.
He also begins to work on two volumes
dealing with politics and kingship.
During his time in Asshole,
Sandra social met,
fell in love with and married the
niece of Hmi is named five theists,
soon adult who was born who
was also named five years.
Soon,
officer us was attacked
by the Persians and gang.
Homies was taken captive and executed.
Iris doesn't lend his family.
They relocated to the island of Lesbos
where they spent the next two years.
It was here that he indulged in his
passion for the study of marine life.
The work the terrorists were conducted
on the islands gave rise to a whole new
scientific discipline,
biology,
the study of life.
He was relentlessly systematic
in his classifications.
Creatures they were divided into
laundry grieves according to their
characteristics.
This resulted in the publication of
three books that minute detail of the
characteristics of living things.
He also studied the ecology of the islands
in 343 BC.
Iris also received an
invitation from Philip.
The second is the king of massive
dome to come and tutor his son,
Alexander,
who was 13 at the time.
I accepted and moved his
family to Macedonia where he
became the director of the
Royal Academy.
King Philip had a reputation as an
uncouth and uneducated barbarian warrior.
He was proud of his son,
was developing the same
strength of resolve and wanted
the prince to balance his
strength with knowledge and with wisdom,
and he feared that the instruction that
was being provided by the boys too.
It is when you create
another version of himself.
It was these concerns that prompted
the king to call for the great teacher,
Aristotle or the academy.
Aristotle taught Alexander and other
young members of the royal household and a
style reminiscence of
the platonic academy.
He instructed them in morality,
in logic,
as well as the arts and medicine.
In addition,
one on one lessons were given to Alexander
the only was impetuous and stub and
often challenging and
resisting as teacher.
However,
aristotle exhibited a great patient,
says he shaped and molded
the thinking of the future,
conquer his superior reasoning,
inevitably one over the prince.
One of Aristotle's greatest challenges
was to reign in Alexander's impetuous
nature in one memorable
exchange and also the prince.
What the most valuable virtue
was that a soldier could possess.
Alexandra immediately
replied that it was courage,
but what aristotle last would happen
if the war he has excess courage,
cost and to run ahead of his army
and face the enemy all alone.
Alexander acknowledge that
he would surely be killed.
What though the teacher
asked what happened,
and if a lack of courage cause the
soldier to run the other direction,
well then he would be a coward.
Came on exam,
just reply by this exchange.
Aristotle taught Alexander the importance
of always finding the middle pines and
therefore developing
balance in one's life.
Aristotle also educated Alexander in
the warrior hero traditions of the past.
He provided the teenager with a copy
of the Iliad and is encouraged in the
opponent assuming rulerships conquer the
barbarian lands to the East Aristotle
House,
very ethnocentric view of non Greeks,
which he doubtedly passed onto his people.
He viewed them as fits only for slavery.
Ends famously gave this piece of advice
to the future and be a leader to the
Greeks,
and they dispatched to the barbarians
to look after the former as friends and
relatives and to deal with the latter.
As with beasts or plants,
Iris Delta was able to cultivate in the
teenage prints a love of reading and of
learning for the rest of his life.
Alexander remains an avid
reader developing a special
love for the writings of
homer.
It is claimed the Eland,
all 15,693 lines of poetry
in the Eliana by heart.
The princes education at the
ends of the great philosopher.
It came to an abrupt halt in 340 BC.
Alexander was the 16 year old out of
the throne and he was called to Pella to
rule over Macedonia while
his father was off waging war
by 335 BC,
Alexander and succeeded his
father as king one visit.
First acts was to conquer Athens,
which paved the way for our results are
returned to the city where he had spent
his formative years,
Plato's academy,
which was now run by a former student
names and socrates was still the leading
influence on Greek thinking.
However,
aristotle was given permission
by Alexandra to start up
his own rival academy.
As a foreigner,
aristotle was not able to
own property in Athens.
As a result,
he rented a building called the Lyceum,
which was a former wrestling
school and outside of the city.
Unlike Plato's academy,
the Lyceum was not a private club for
half of the day are still some tutors
which teach that Peng
students in advanced topics.
Then the doors would be opened and the
lectures and discussion would be free of
charge.
It's open to anyone who
wish to attend narrow,
soulful spent the bulk of
the remainder of his life.
Working at the Lyceum,
he develops a unique style teaching his
students while they wandered around the
gardens of the school.
This gave rise to the
nickname peripatetics,
meaning people who wonder about this
guy of study at the lyceum was vast.
Aristotle wanted his students to research
and write about every area of human
thought from mathematics to biology,
philosophy,
politics,
and the rhetoric.
Students were required to write their
arguments down in manuscript form.
These were collected
in the lyceums library,
which became one of the first great
collections of historical writings,
and sometime during the first few
years after his return to Athens,
Aristotle's wife Pythius,
she died.
It is believed that the Persian
king upsets the terrorists.
Delta has helped to arrange
and aligns with Macedonia.
Had pythius arrest is then executed.
Aristotle.
He was heartbreaking in his grief.
He read the poem of
his life that survived,
which he titled an Ode
to Virtue in science,
though Aristotle,
he became romantically involved
with a woman named her phyllis.
Some accounts states that,
uh,
phyllis was a slave who had been given
to aristotle by the court of Alexander,
but this cannot be verified.
The two never married,
but I fill this bore aristotle,
many children,
the first of whom they named Nick and
MCASS after aristotle's father have
phyllis remains with
aristotle until his death.
During the years that our stuff was
established as lyceum metathesis,
former people,
Alexander was very busy conquering
the known world as his power grew,
so did his ego,
the veggies that the philosopher has
instilled in him with cost aside as he
became increasingly megalomaniacal.
Eventually he proclaimed himself to be
divine and requires that all peoples
prostrate themselves before him in
all of his status as a living going on
aristotle's recommendation,
his nephew Callis,
the knees had been appointed as an office,
a story of Alexander's Asiatic expedition.
Palestinians was concerned
about the kings out of control,
ego and somewhat foolishly let his
concerns be known and well this led to his
execution.
Then in 323 BC,
the 32 year old Alexander and he
suddenly died soon thereafter,
the pro Macedonian governments.
It was forcibly removed.
The Athenians web now back in control
into backlash was unleashed against the
Macedonians.
Aristotle is the leading Macedonian
intellect and supporter of Alexander was a
prime target of the new regime and he
was formally charged with impiety or not
believing in the gods of the state.
This was the same charge that had been
leveled at socrates and it led to his
conviction and his execution,
stating that he refused to allow
Athens do sin against philosophy twice.
Aristotle decided not to
stay and defend himself.
He fled the city and headed for the
islands of your beer where his mother's
estate was located.
He died on the islands in 323 BC.
You have natural causes.
It was 62 years of age.
Now,
normally this is where a
graphics video would end,
but there is much more
about aristotle to come,
but first I do want to
thank today's sponsor,
brilliant and I know ads
in the middle of the video.
They aren't great that sponsors like
brilliant do make these longer videos,
possible brilliance or assigns learning
platform that allow you to learn through
active learning,
which summed up is basically the opposite
of that feeling of reading a complex
paragraph about some principle and then
just having absolutely no clue about
what they were going on about,
you know,
even though you read it 10 times,
still got no idea what's
happening and brilliant.
Don't just cover the basics or
they totally covered those as well.
They go all the way through to really
complex things like advanced statistics,
brilliant,
makes even complex statistical concepts,
very easy to understand,
but they're giving you
something super short to read.
It's easy,
and then you've immediately apply what
you just read to a problem and rinse and
repeat and boom.
Suddenly you understand stuff that you
didn't really think it ever be able to
understand.
I've used brilliant to do just this.
It's pretty amazing how quickly
you grasped such complex subjects.
You can spoil biographics
by going to brilliant.org,
forward slash buyer graphics,
and now let's get back to aristotle.
Yeah,
Aristotle had died as an enemy of
the state and so memory of him,
it was discouraged.
However,
his students and friend
Theophrastus kept says,
writing secretly hidden while also
taking the reins of the lyceum.
The works of Aristotle did not see the
light of day until the beginning of the
first century BC when they became
appreciated throughout the Roman world.
After the fall of Rome,
aristotle became familiar to
the Islamic world as well,
where many thinkers,
if the time came to appreciate,
is logical deductive methodology.
In fact,
it was largely because of his
popularity and the Byzantium worlds that
aristotle's teachings were
able to survive the dark ages.
It was during the 13th century.
See this,
aristotle was reintroduced to the west.
This was achieved primarily
through the work of Thomas Aquinas,
who attempted to amalgamate religious
beliefs with science and philosophy.
Aquinas incorporated Aristotle's assertion
that a wrath lies at the center of
the universe as a fundamental
tenets of Catholicism.
During the renascence
and reformation years,
a succession of religious reformers
and scientists began to question some
aristotle,
he and beliefs that had been
absorbed into the Catholic church.
One of them was the Italian astronomer,
Galileo,
who presented observational proof
that the earth orbiting the sun.
It's ironic that while aristotle was
undoubtedly have embraced this new
observation the Catholic
church fathers made,
Galileo appeared before the
inquisition and recant a session.
English physicist William Harvey later
discovered that internal organs don't
work the way that aristotle had status.
Another of Aristotle's views that was
disproved was that decay only happens on
the Earth while the heavens never change.
Nineteenth Century astronomists Lord
Calvin challenged this notion with the
concept of entropy,
which states that all matter,
whether earthly or heavenly,
will eventually decay.
Aristotle also told the planets and
stars are all encased in crystalline
spheres.
Each one nested inside the next with the
earth being the intimate sphere by the
18th century.
The contradictory idea that the planets
hang on a void was gaining acceptance.
Aristotle wrote some 10 million words
in order to preserve his thoughts.
Unfortunately,
the majority of them have not
survived the passing of the years.
The manuscripts were been covered in the
first century BC when they were edited
by a man named Andronicus.
The works that we have today are derived
from Andronico's as edited versions,
and so we're not directly prepared
for publication by Aristotle.
Today,
we are able to read about a million of
Aristotle's which represents some 20
percent of his total work as a result
of the paucity of writings that we have,
we are only able to see a shadow
of the brilliance of aristotle.
The quality of the pros,
which has been lost to us,
was hinted dance by
Roman statesmen Cicero.
He went declaring aristotle's
ratings to those of Plato declared.
If Plato pros with silver,
aristotle's was a flowing river of gold.
The works of Aristotle that have survived
are grouped into four categories.
First is the organization in which
quantify a set of logical principles to
follow when conducting an investigation
then comes the theoretical consisting of
a range of treatises on the natural world.
The practical mechanic refocuses,
focuses on achieving excellence
within the individual,
the family,
and in society.
Finally,
the rhetoric writing collect together,
aristotle,
surviving political and
philosophical speeches.
Aristotle divided the sciences
into three categories.
The productive,
the practical and the
theoretical productive sciences
encompasses such things as
building an architecture,
but also battlefield strategy
in courtroom tactics.
There's also practical sciences which
cover ethics and guided behavior.
The theoretical sciences,
which included mathematics and physics
and full of the quest for knowledge and
understanding is that own end results,
the scope of Aristotle's
scientific research.
It was staggering.
His writings feature minute
descriptions of more than 500 species,
some of the features that he observed.
We're not verified until the
invention of the microscope.
Thousands of years later,
his detailed observations
included the Anatomy Dot,
habitat and reproductive
system of the fish,
insects,
and animals that he observed.
While on the island of Lesbos.
A trademark of Aristotle's thinking was
that evidence was the ultimate arbiter
of truth.
Regardless of what theories you may hold.
If observation proved them wrong,
then yeah,
must have the humility to discard
them and go with the evidence.
Despite being challenged
with impiety aristotle,
he did believe in God.
However,
his God did not create or control
the universe but could affect it.
He viewed God as the
ultimate abstract reason.
I considered that the highest level of
attainment for a human is to as closely
emulate God's ability to reason abstractly
as possible so the person could get
to this heightened ability to reason
the closer they would be to God himself.
Aristotle's greatest contribution to
mankind was that he provided a methodology
by which to find solutions to problems
rather than providing the solutions
themselves.
When he did come to conclusions,
he was careful to qualify it by stating
that the conclusion was based upon the
evidence available at the time.
If new evidence was to come to live
so that proved his conclusions wrong,
then he would discount them.
However,
during the period known as the Christian
Middle Ages between 476 and 1,453 ce,
Aristotle's methodology was cast aside
and the focus went squarely on his
conclusions,
which contrary to his wishes
were accepted without question.
So rather than observing
nature to find the answers,
they simply accepted what aristotle
had written on the subject.
Plato and Aristotle ended up with very
different philosophical approaches.
Plato was the ultimate idealist,
but leaving the world around us
is merely a collection of ideas.
On the other hand,
aristotle was a realist to believe that
the only reality was the physical world
which we inhabit.
Each man would provide a
work of political philosophy.
In Plato's case,
it was entitled the Republic,
while Aristotle called.
Here's the politic.
Plato's work was focused on
achieving the ideal state.
He believed that one way to achieve this
was through the eradication of private
property,
the family and gender roles.
By doing away with these
societal norms play,
Jay was hoping to transcend
human selfishness in order
to achieve social unity.
Aristotle,
however rejects it,
the end goal of Plato's ideal state,
he contended that selfishness
is a part of human nature.
His idea was to design a government that
acknowledged human selfishness and it's
putting in place checks and
balances to mitigate it.
He pointed out the impracticality of
Plato's views asking such questions as who
would look after the children if
they weren't part of a family.
If other contended that human selfishness
is one of the driving forces that
results in achievement.
Aristotle devised a working government
he referred to as policy and it was
balanced between the rich and the poor
with neither one dominating the other
end.
People were forced to work together
for the overall good of society while
retaining their property rights.
One of the hallmarks of aristotle's method
of arguments was logical developments
where each point builds upon the last.
This was very different to plato who
would jump all over the place with his
ideas.
In contrast,
aristotle emphasize the need for mental
discipline by which those engaged in
debate would stay focused
on the topic at hand plays.
I was mainly concerned with
the accumulation of knowledge.
He believed that ideas were subjective
and could be influenced by personal
views.
Aristotle on the other hand was focused
on observation and the examination of
what is real.
He was an objective thinker who did not
allow a place for emotion or personal
opinion play,
so was an idea list.
He believed,
for example,
but knowing good was enough
for a person to do God.
Aristotle,
however,
argued that knowing good
was not good enough,
a person had to practice being good to
benefit himself as well as society plays.
They also believed that every
concept has an ideal form,
whereas aristotle was a view that every
concept and needed to be studied on an
individual level in
order to understand it.
Plato was of the view that reasoning and
thought experiments were sufficient to
prove matters.
Whereas Aristotle relies upon direct
experience as a results of their differing
approaches.
The scientific contributions of aristotle
were much greater than those of us
teacher Plato.
The lastest teachings were
predominantly theoretical,
lacking practicality,
whereas aristotle,
he's left us with the scientific method
which grounded in practical observation.
So I really hope you found
this video interesting.
If he did do,
give us a thumbs up below and
please don't forget to subscribe.
If you want to see more biographics,
we put out several videos just like this,
so hit that subscribe button
and hit that notification bell.
If you actually want to find
out when we put our videos,
youtube doesn't work how it used to and
if you want to see something else by us,
we got some videos from the archive
link to you on the screen and as always,
thank you for watching.